well the summer movie season is over but
we can still be surprised you know we
Americans we like saying things in
Spanish I don't know why it makes us
feel like cool hip and relevant you know
it's kind of like having an Asian letter
tattooed all right so last summer in the
movie theaters we saw a trailer to the
movie devil and when M night Shyamalan s
name came up on the screen everyone in
the theater started booing and let's
face it M night Shyamalan is kind of
like to show Heroes at first we were all
like this is so awesome and now we're
all just like let's just forget that
that ever happened but to set the record
straight Shyamalan is the producer Andy
came up with the story so ultimately he
was just like I had this idea for this
movie I think I'm gonna write this one
down and someone else was just like oh
yeah that's a good idea I'll give you
that but how about I go ahead and write
this one down and I've seen your movies
for the past six years so I didn't take
a nap but Shyamalan was off crushing a
franchise so he really had nothing to do
with this movie other than coming up
with the idea and making sure it got
made so the movie devil stars and
revolves around five people stuck in an
elevator together and then attacks and
death and sue and you're stuck trying to
figure out who's doing it and why it's
kind of like clue only it only takes
place in an elevator now judging by the
booze and the movie theaters and my own
thoughts on the subject expectations for
devil were not very high for me but I
guess you cannot judge a movie by its
producer you know once every few years a
movie comes out and before you see
you're just like I'm gonna hate this
movie so much it is going to suck so
much suck in fact I'm gonna watch it
just so I can hate it this much yeah me
neither
be weird and then you see it you're like
actually wasn't that bad it was actually
pretty good that is pretty much exactly
what this movie's like it shouldn't be
but it is I mean it's interesting and it
kept you guessing you're like I am
convinced that that person is the one
who's doing it right there I mean that's
the devil or the killer or whoever is
doing this and why then you're guessing
about the characters like who are they
and why is this happening to them and
does that matter
hell let's face it five people who don't
trust each other all within like a three
by three space that's cool and it did
have a couple of creepy ass moments some
were those jump scares that I usually
hate but others weren't I mean the
movies about an hour and fifteen minutes
long which sounds really
when you say it like that but I mean
it's perfect for this movie if it were
any longer it'd be trying too hard and
if it were any shorter it'd be a
Twilight Zone episode not that that's a
bad thing I'd say if you like The
Twilight Zone if you like the Outer
Limits if you hate The Last Airbender
and you like movies where you're trying
to figure out what's going on as people
are sequentially getting picked off thus
the suspects are narrowing you'll
probably like devil I don't know why
that last airbender thing matters but I
think it does so a movie called devil is
actually good which could only mean one
thing someone sold their soul if it
comes in first this weekend maybe then
they sold their soul I mean because how
bad would that be if you sell your soul
and come in second I don't know let's
ask so even though the cool thing about
this movie is trying to figure out
what's going on so replay value in
movies like that usually isn't too high
but in terms of judging how good the
movie is I would say I'd buy this movie
even on blu-ray
there's no catch I just think it's good
and if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more than click
right here to see more you won't even
have to sign away your soul if you don't
want to
[Music]